so if the question here for both of
these is graph because right now we're
focused on stationary points and points
of inflection what they will do is they
will craft the question such that it has
a certain number of stationary points or
a certain kind of inflection point all
that kind of thing
one of the interesting things which
takes take some genuine thought it took
me quite a few years after I started and
realizes is if you craft a question
because of their nature of
differentiation
if you craft a question so it's got nice
stationary points then almost always you
will have messy intercepts or vice versa
if you have anything of complexity like
not a parabola basically if you have
nice intercepts that your stationery
points will be a tweed awkward spots
which is what happens with this okay yes
so we're gonna have nice I suspect these
coefficients have been chosen to make
the stationery points easy to find
whereas the if you have a look like how
am I supposed to factorize this to get
the X intercepts and it's like well
there's not a nice pairing of things
that it's just gross right and of course
we don't really have tools to deal with
a degree power4 so yeah but that's okay
we can still we can still do a lot so
the first thing to notice is I can this
is going to be a quartic curve so we
know a parabola looks something like
that right a cube it looks something
like that you can see a parabola has a
power of two which gives it one
stationary point because if it has a
power of two its derivative it has a
power of one does that make sense so
therefore one stationary point this is a
cubic with power three so therefore its
derivative has a power of two which is
why we often find not every time because
you can have you can have this guy right
but we we often find two stationary
points therefore logic sort of if you
follow along right if you have a quartic
then its derivative will have a power of
three which is why you can expect that
there will be one or two or three
stationary points just like this you can
have combinations so for example you can
have one looks like this
so you can have a stationary point there
and then you have a horizontal point of
inflection there so we have different
combinations so we'll find out once we
start to get to work okay so I we we
need to find all these features so let's
differentiate that gives us this
whatever yeah 4 X cube help me out with
the rest of it you can be get minus 48
48 I think it's 48 x squared plus cool
and that's all you get
yeah all right good so before I get to
like test this and all I kind of think
while I'm in a differentiating mood I
might as well do the second derivative
now I'm doing this so that I could
determine nature why did I use the
second derivative test not the first
review yeah like I'm going to use this
in a second to find out the nature of
the stationary points why did I choose
to go second review rather first yeah
they do I've written them icily the main
reason why if you think about that big
enormous flow chart I drew before the
main reason why I choose second
derivative rather the first derivative
is because this is very easy to
differentiate like polynomials are super
easy later on like well if you do with
something like this I do not want to
differentiate that again I'll do it once
because I have to find stationary points
but I'm going to avoid doing it twice
like the plague okay so I will
differentiate this again that gives you
12x squared take away 96 X plus a
hundred forty four okay so now let's
work with these things but this this
first derivative here I've got a whole
bunch of common factors right in fact I
can see that 4x is a common factor what
does that leave behind x squared take
away 12x plus 30 30 mmm
144 divided by 4 well right no come on
we could do this is that 30 it's 36
isn't it yeah oh yeah okay
for flex your numerical rustles it's
healthy for you okay because also like
that's how you spot errors more quickly
because if you think about this when
you're checking back to a paper you
don't usually check with a calculator
you just look at the numbers you like
look right and if you don't have the
mental rigor to be able to say wait a
second it has the huh
you know it's just a useful thing to do
having done this we can factorize
further can't we because 36 this is a
perfect square isn't it so in fact it's
4x outside of X minus 6 okay which makes
me suspicious
all right let's let's have a look at
this so therefore I'm not going to worry
too much about my working here because
the question is graphed so the primary
thing I'm producing is the graph and all
this working is just subsidiary they're
not really going to mark my working
they're gonna mark my graph so therefore
I'm gonna play a bit faster looser
things so if I learnt stationary points
I'll abbreviate that because I'm just in
a hurry right and I'm not worried about
the working then they exist when the
first derivative is zero right which is
when x equals great so when x equals
zero that's kid video because that was
that's going to give you the y intercept
anyway when x equals zero y is going to
be 0 0 0 10 okay this one let's use our
calculators when x equals 6 on the other
hand we're going to have 6 6 cubes is
right 216 so 6 ^ or is 1296 - my brain
is already melted my house I have no
idea that's right
4:42 okay so fine it's a big number but
that's okay we'll just adjust our scale
accordingly okay
so I notice that both stationary points
they're both for positive values of Y so
most of the stuff is happening above the
x-axis so let's just draw a very rough
sort of thing here so when x equals zero
y equals 10 but when x equals 6 y equals
442 that is huge so I'm going to put
some markers here let's call this a
hundred 200 300 400 500 all right in
order to get to there so when x equals
six one two three four five six I'm
somewhere between 400 and 500 so let's
call that over here well well it's not
considered the x and y axes are not the
same scale but they don't need to be so
I'm okay with that so if this is 400 and
this is 500 and this is x equals 6 then
that point there is 10 comma 4 4 sorry 6
comma 4 4 to 6 comma 4 fortune okay and
of course I also have my y-intercept
here so that's gonna be way down here at
10 okay how are we looking so far now
at this point I'm going to take
advantage of the fact that because this
is a polynomial I know a lot about how
polynomials work for instance you know
with the parabola right parabolas are
either concave up or concave down how
can you tell really quickly in a single
look which one it is
well okay you can't go to calculate
there's a quicker way yeah you're
looking for the coefficient we call it
the leading coefficient it's the
coefficient attached to the biggest
power of X right now if of course this
was a quadratic then the bigger power of
X would be 2 so you'd say all possible 2
so I could cave up right now it's the
same deal for any kind of polynomial
right so if you think of X to the 4 you
can see there's cortex which are
basically going up and then there are
cortex which are basically going
down okay and you can't you can't have
both right you wanna have both like a
pair down you'd need an odd polynomial
that's because of this think about when
you put large values into here right
when you put large values of X into here
this guy becomes a huge positive number
which basically Dwarfs everything else
that's happening here even though you
like X cubed that still be too big but
next to X to the 4 it's like a
grasshopper okay
when you put in negative values of X
very large ones what's this guy doing
it's still gonna be a large positive
number large positive right on the other
hand if I were to slap a minus sign out
the front you're going to get this
situation because it's gonna be negative
times a positive number and negative
times a positive number whichever way
you go okay now because it's positive I
know it's gonna look like one of these
like that so when I have a look at this
right remember I've got to come from the
top down and then I've got to go up so I
actually already have an educated guess
as to what kind of stationary points
these are right I'm guessing that that's
a minimum I'm guessing that's a
horizontal point of inflection it can't
turn around cuz they don't end up down
here so I'm gonna use my second
derivative to confirm that okay let's
have a look when x equals zero that's
our first stationary point right you can
look at this very quickly right when x
equals zero what is the sign of the
second derivative yeah the number is 144
which is positive right
so this one is concave up that make
sense when you put in x equals six 12
times 36 minus 96 I don't I don't know
oh but I would put some lay down that at
zero is a zero BAM
okay now keep in mind concavity zero
could look like this or it could look
like if that or it can look like that
but the point is that it's straight
however I also know it's a stationary
point that means it's got a horizontal
tangent so this is what's happening
right for that little spot there
okay so that just confirms if I had to
if I if I had multiple parts of this and
like the first part of the question
before you graph was find the stationary
points and determine their nature this
doesn't cut it I've got to go further
right I haven't proven for instance that
this is a horizontal point of inflection
I need to know that there's a change in
concavity of both sides
I haven't established that but I I know
enough clues about this that I could
just go for it
that's really all the information that I
need I'm gonna draw it like this oh yeah
I'm done okay which by the way because
this is a minimum right because this is
a bit of it's concave up right that's
why they're actually don't accept
x-intercepts that's why we were looking
at like right so there aren't any
accidents of such a shape okay so just
to rewind like just to review what do we
do what we do we differentiate it we
knew we had to do that
find your stationary points determine
their nature and then fit it together in
a picture that makes sense of the
features that you've got okay if I had
no idea
yep or if I really didn't know very much
I would actually probably go back to the
first derivative and I draw up a table
of values because the table of values
that I would get I would get two numbers
that tell me this like I would get
negative gradient 0 positive gradient 0
positive gradient again and that quite
accurately tells me what's going on I
know it's a continuous curve it's just a
polynomial there's no values of x that
break it down there's no don't nominate
R so I know I'm gonna get a smooth curve
of some kind the only one that fits this
looks like that ok